el éxodo continúa a mediante las fuerzas
rusas avanzan en el territorio ucraniano
más de 1.700.000 personas han tenido que
salir del país según acnur y la unión
europea calcula que muchas más cruzarán
las fronteras de ucrania si la guerra se
prolonga sin bombas de montini diconsa
si los bombardeos continúan si las
ciudades siguen siendo bombardeadas
indiscriminadamente podemos esperar 5
millones de inmigrantes no inmigrantes
no podemos llamarlos inmigrantes son
personas que intentan escapar de la
guerra y se pelean
habrá entonces un problema en la
frontera oriental de europa y debemos
hacer todo lo que podamos
con los países vecinos se preparan para
que el flujo de personas persista tras
cerca de dos semanas de guerra hungría
ya recibió 180.000 ucranianos eslovaquia
128 mil mientras que rumanía y moldavia
han hecho lo propio con cerca de 80 mil
refugiados la situación es especialmente
crítica en polonia país que ya reportó
haber acogido más de un millón de
personas en la ciudad fronteriza polaca
de médica largas filas se forman bajo la
nieve
un autobús para continuar con su camino
muchos voluntarios acuden a dicho punto
para brindar apoyo estamos intentando
ayudar a que los refugiados entren en
calor con mantas de supervivencia pero
también para reconfortar sus corazones
con una sonrisa y palabras amables el
gobierno polaco ha anunciado que planea
crear un fondo de mil 750 millones de
dólares una política migratoria que
varias ongs han catalogado de
contradictoria y marcada por actos
racistas en medio de la crisis de
refugiados de ucrania que acnur ha
catalogado como el éxodo más rápido al
interior de europa desde la segunda
guerra mundial